Joe Biden is set to speak any minute now
and uh it is believed he's going to
advocate for us involvement in Ukraine
and Israel he's going to be requesting
100 billion do he's already pledged 100
million to Palestine which I I think
sends a horrible sign and signal to
Hamas that if they engage in Terror
they're going to get paid off to the
tune of hundreds of hundred plus million
dollars or100 million do but uh we're
we're going to we're going to take a
look at uh Joe Biden's speech and hear
what he has to say as well as bring up a
bunch of other news Sydney has pleaded
guilty and will be testifying against
other defendants that means likely she
will be testifying against Trump The
Dominoes Begin to Fall because they're
all going to start selling each other
out but we'll see how many people
actually believed what they were
preaching and will stand up for their
conviction so